he's concentrating out looking at
grasshoppers legs it got stripes y'all
can sit here and get bit if you want to
[Laughter]
are we in Florida oh my god wait my
joints feel like but us myself I came
back and things actually got worse look
at this
whoa - do you have some cashews game the
game is busted listen up now this is a
dangerous place you got to have eyes in
the back
Sam Hale just happening I see you all
absolutely love this movie wonderful new
addition to the cast I was wondering if
you could maybe kick off this interview
with a little Jumanji song Jack it's the
jungle inside I just saw somewhere deep
inside at the end I just love Nora's
reaction for that song it gets me every
well you know cuz it's true well now I'm
gonna break now gonna put you on the
spot because you're the new addition to
the cast
last time I interviewed you I asked for
everybody's hidden talent I want to know
if there is if you can do the smoldering
intensity one eyebrow tween you know I
think yeah I think you just did it sorry
I always mesmerize first I couldn't and
you have any hidden talent yeah okay
ready how are they not using this in the
film one of your strengths
this could be one of your tricks right
now there's a reason for another it's
actually Mozart when you don't say the
lyrics because it's twinkle twinkle
little stars yeah okay I'll show you
mine what is happening is that raving
what do you raise what is it no one
knows can you do the ear wiggle at the
same time I know you have that town I
feel well no not at the same time those
are separate and I don't do it very good
here
you're more wiggling like yours the side
of your face it's subtle no stop next
question what are you talking about left
now okay watch watch actor would you
have playing you guys if you were stuck
in a video games who would play your
avatar
oh good Corbin yeah or the other way
around
yeah to play you if you got stuck in a
video gaming there's a movie about it
who would play you so like are they
sorry you're stuck in a game what would
you what body would you want to take
John Cena that's a good one I'd go with
Hussein Bolt Usain Bolt fast bro yeah
I'm going Armstrong
dad young one more quick question what's
the craziest place you've watched a
movie if there has been a crazy Clay she
watched a movie iPhone screen like a
weird unusual place to watch a movie
like I went there and I guess why I did
I watched a movie where I know candy
being on an iPhone screen that's what I
was gonna say we went camping out in
jumbo rock out in Joshua Tree and
someone had one of those portable
projectors that was just like oh yeah
and you projected up on a rock and you
watch amazing would you watch it was
like the one about the cavemen animated
movie about the cavemen I think Nicholas
Cage they played the dad of the village
secrets which made sense on the side of
a boulder yeah it does no it's very
fitting can we go out with an eyebrow
raise whatever it is Oh
and eyebrow raised I think I'm really
nailing it terrible job what are you
talking about that's passed my driver's
test last month okay we're not gonna
make it we're gonna make it hopefully
we're gonna make it we're gonna make it
we're not gonna make it wonderful to see
you both together see you I'm gonna put
you on the spot first Yeah right away
The Rock is playing you in this movie I
want to know if you can do the one
eyebrow raised smoldering intensity
how's that I mesmerised miss brush it
happens it's just not you out I won't
ask you to do Kevin unless you want to
do you idiot Kevin I'm living right now
thank you guys this is now we know
what's gonna happen in the next Jumanji
yeah right yeah yeah
would you want it to believe them in the
kitchen would you want to go to the
jungle and right there you go that's
fine we're good we're good Mouse what do
you think because the two of you have
been in some great comedy duo's over the
years what is the key Kevin in the
rocker so it's like caring for each
other and like giving and being generous
and all those things that make it like
it's something that a partnership yeah
otherwise it's like you know but there
have been a lot of historical head butts
yeah in the world you know that work you
know what I mean so you go is hearing
stories about that I think that it's
more fun I think probably for everybody
that they get along and I think they
know it too so it probably is like the
best way to go is there a trait of each
other that you wish you could borrow
would you is there a trait of this Danny
that you would like to borrow and vice
versa
I think his taste in clothes I would I
would like probably like it's so
comfortable with him though you know I
think I'm always thinking about how we
get to where we are it starts to where
we become comfortable with ourselves you
know and
and I think that's one of the things
I've always felt about Danny here
whenever I'm sorry Clem even from taxi
from the beginning it was just so
comfortable in itself you know he's my
favorite person watches nobody checks
you beautiful we had a great time
together yeah yeah and what about of the
people that are playing you is there
something in the rock that you wouldn't
you really admire and is there something
in Kevin that you most admire I think
like you know his discipline is like
amazing I mean it takes care of himself
really in a good way you know I mean
it's like I think it's somebody like
eight meals a day eats like good food
he's like takes care works out concern
debate and he's you know he's as gentle
as you can get I wouldn't like you know
like oh but he's really cool yeah you
know I can feel it sometimes you feel
people out you know you you just discard
up but they look like physically and
just feel this spirit out and they both
have such great spirit I'm gonna play
Angwin I think it's a great thing
because you know penguin is a great part
Oswald Cobblepot as many many layers
it's very very difficult task but I
think you know like many people have
played like you know King Lear
or Hamlet or anything I don't think
Oswald should be any different I think
everybody should get a crack out of you
and I think Colin is a terrific actor I
can't wait to see the twists and turns
would you look at me I haven't looked
like this since never you look like this
never I think my eyes are a different
color all of you is it different
first of all okay my relationship with
Fandango is so good I'm not sure if you
notice but I got a lot of records over
there
we gave you a belt then we give you a
choice because we were family out or you
while you have the relationship with
vendee I have a relationship with her
because it's all about relationships Wow
to me oh okay no well no yes
complimentary
that was there it is right there just
letting the camera know Kevin doesn't
like insects just gonna say yes so guys
right here some are you alright DJ I'm
good okay are you ready I'm ready
are you said okay so we both know that
you're both incredibly talented credibly
handsome you're incredibly successful
Duane I want to know what Kevin needs to
do to take it to the next level
Kevin what is Duane need to do to take
it to the next level hmm what is the way
you need to do to take it to the next
level you know what nothing really I
think that you just should embrace the
opportunities in the moments and seize
them when they come
Wow yeah well that was very nice are you
gonna be that nice where am i left now
to go where do you go I can't to others
so now what Kevin you know what you're
already it's sometimes it's impossible
to go to yet another level when you're
as high as this man is so we're keeping
the conversation high we're not right
now we're not going to give it time okay
we're gonna bring it here all right
we'll see if you like this one in 30
years from now I'd love to know what
your relationship is going to be like
what you two are gonna sound like but I
want you to swap bodies oh great okay oh
I can uh
okay so 30 years DJ what is this oh I
don't want to eat this
[Laughter]
you liar I'm out Kevin in 30 years from
now would be like that see I can't
he's no cheat raining out look at that
grasshoppers legs it got stripes y'all
can sit here and get a bit if you want
to grassman that's a blue nose you're
definitely in Jumanji right now we got
to go so between the two you both nailed
the Danny's thank you what do you think
nailed it just a little bit more did it
no you can't it's it's such it's so
equal in in completion like the the goal
and task at hand was to do our best
versions of the legend Danny DeVito
Danny Glover and when you see your
partner come to the table your partner's
equipped and ready and he sees that
you're equipped and ready there's a
moment of knowing I got the right guy on
my side
and we got the right team yeah like it's
it's it's not about who's who's better
it's how do we make each other better so
the the minute that we start thinking
about me me me as a minute that this
thing that we have falls apart it's it's
we have to elevate a gyro today
no I the truth is I you know we didn't
talk to each other prior to shooting
since the two Danny's didn't talk to
each other in the movie so we kind of
stayed separate so I had no idea what
Kevin was bringing to the table in terms
of his in terms of his his performance
and he had not heard my DeVito
performance either so when we get to set
and he breaks out his his Danny Glover
and then I break out my DeVito we were
just we the day ended with us bent over
laughing I mean it was just so but then
also too I mean what a real honor that
we get a chance to do this because it's
also I think a testament to just like
the cool magic of Jumanji in this world
of Jumanji in that you know these
avatars that we are in the movie can be
embodied by anyone the DeVito so if
you're saying that who would you like to
play you guys if somebody if you guys
got stuck in a video game who would you
like to play you like the one you mean
yeah uh oh my god you know what it
probably non crew for you you say time
to me that's right that's really funny
that's really good actually Tom Cruise
don't make me it would be very funny
would you go which actually you doing
Tom Cruise I mean either I'm thinking
can you do Tom Cruise oh I gotta watch
something and get a cadence and I would
be able to to do it I'd rather watch
something to do it um you know what I
would go you know what be a dog thing
Pierce was his name James Bond here's
boss me yeah so um this is it's just a
cooler a cooler version something
different and something that you
wouldn't expect I'm just trying to think
of the opposites
you know you can go scarlet Johannsen
yes yeah yeah yeah what what do you do
I'm not being inappropriate things like
she would embody you I didn't make that
face I didn't make that mouth well I did
not make that ugly face no she's just
friend of mine that's not like that okay
I mean I'm just I'm just saying it's
just this men embody heart yes that's
what it means is it gonna have a
different tone I heard little rumors
that maybe Kevin's gonna have her
illness these are rumors these effects
these are facts what is the character
and how is this gonna have it is it
gonna have a different tone from the
usual DC movies that we've seen I mean
they've been breaking out and doing
different things with Joker I think
black Adam is gonna have its own tone
and temperament and you know with black
Adam we want to do things that are a
little different than what has been done
in the world of DC and I mean that
respectfully considering Joker
considering the new Wonder Woman coming
out considering what they've done with
Aquaman and movies in the past but our
producer Hiram Garcia said it best in
that describing black Adam it is you
know there's a new hierarchy of power
that's coming within the DC Universe and
his name is black Adams and in terms of
Kevin Kevin does have a role in black at
it and we're gonna reveal it here it's
black Adam and white Adam why that him I
want it to be silk shirt can I please be
soldier well that's the thing I mean I
don't know how much of a badass I can be
able to sew shirt on let me tell you
something about white and white adamant
because he doesn't like anything he does
like anything white and he also has a
problem with enunciation so I can't I
can't use the letter T and that's that's
a thing
right but he has to say it's a thing
good but you gotta fly to the top of the
building but I can do I can do so the
thing we're gonna counter with we're
figuring it out right now
you